Hi, beautiful people.
Here I am answering a question about B F D.
I have actually decided
that I'll be answering the questions that I'm getting.
Yeah. So for you to do the volunteer EAR program
or the BFD or FSRT or FSJ,
I mean, in German,
you need German language skills.
Like, remember,
you are going to work in a social institution.
So it's important for you to.
To at least have basic German language skills.
Let's say at least A1A2B,
one around there.
But without language skills,
you can't volunteer. So, guys,
if you're interested in doing this program in Germany,
it's better for you to start learning the language.
Come to my YouTube channel and let us learn together.
My YouTube channel is Bridget SC.
Broaden your horizons.